hi I'm Eric Voss and Comic-Con gave us a
new trailer for stranger things season
two set two Michael Jackson's Thriller a
song that is both perfect for this
trailer and too cool for a bunch of
nerds like Mike and all of his friends
now I am obsessed with stranger things
so yeah I did watch his trailer a
million times so much that I keep
experiencing these flashes where I
suddenly wake up inside of the trailer
oh God not again actually this is
awesome can can I stay here so I'm gonna
break down all the stuff I noticed in
this trailer and in case any of these
predictions end up being right spoiler
warning so let's get started
we gotta do this let's engage
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so it looks like stranger things
season two will continue the 80s
Nostalgia that made the show so famous
in season one starting with this
memorable 80s arcade game of Dragon's
Lair now this was a little before my
time but the way it works is you play as
Dirk the daring who's a knight who has
to rescue the way too sexy princess
Daphne from a dragon called singe in a
castle of the evil wizard mordoch and
what made this game special is rather
than feeling like a video game it felt
like you were controlling an animated
narrative and the animation in this was
done by Don Bluth he's the guy who did
the secret of nim also in the 80s who's
a collaborator with Steven Spielberg who
of course is another filmmaker often
referenced in stranger things the two of
them co-produced in American Tail in The
Land Before Time and if you look at the
details here it seems like season two
could begin the same way season one did
with the boys playing this nerdy
nostalgic game that actually foreshadows
the story of the Season perhaps so
remember in season one they play
Dungeons and Dragons with the creature
of the demogorgon surprising them just
like it did in the next team and it was
Will's turn when it happened in the game
and then naturally he was the first
victim and I think Dragon's Lair could
end up foreshadowing season two like
notice how there's this girl who has to
be saved by a beast in a dark magical
place maybe 11 in the demogorgon also we
know episode 4 is called The Palace
which could be what the boys call a
place they have to go to based off of
details from a Dragon's Lair and yeah we
do see someone
a type of Sword later on the way that
Dirk does and this is stranger things so
there's a very good chance that we will
see characters die perhaps similar to
the way that Dirk gets to transformed
into a skeleton actually there are
images of skeletons that show up several
times throughout this trailer
foreshadowing huh we'll see moving on
hey guys do you see the
[Music]
wolf
are you okay
okay so then will hears his voice
Whispering his name and notice this snow
falling outside the arcade I think
that's what Will's about to say here hey
guys do you see the snow but this is
October in Indiana it's a little early
for snow that's because this isn't snow
remember we saw this in season one these
are the Spore type particles of the
upside down this is all designed by
Aaron Sims creative and they were
inspired by the look of games like
Silent Hill in the last of us but then
will goes outside and he sees the source
of this voice the new monster of season
two so what exactly is this thing let's
talk about a few theories the most
likely answer is that this is the vessel
Hydra remember at the end of season one
the boys are playing a new d d game and
the vessel Hydra is the monster so the
deso Hydra is a DND creature with eight
snake heads it's based on the Hydra from
Greek mythology which has three heads
that grow back if you ever cut one off
but clearly the show's designers are
going for an HP Lovecraft kind of look
now Lovecraft is known for massive scale
God type creatures the most well known
of which is Cthulhu they Loom over the
Earth and they're so large that only
pieces of them are just barely visible
through the clouds I think they might be
pulling from another Lovecraft figure
called nyara La thotep might be saying
that wrong kind of sounds like I'm
saying a word in Reverse so unlike the
outer gods of the Cthulhu Universe nyar
lethotep uses human languages to try to
deceive people into thinking that it's
human and I think that sounds a lot like
what this monster is doing to will right
here
speaking to him in his own language to
try to lure him outside and manipulate
him but if we're just looking at the
visuals there could be some other
influences for example the eldrazi from
the magic the Gathering game also the
giant at the end of the Mist the mudo
and Godzilla the monsters and Gareth
Edwards other movie Monsters And as some
of you have pointed out this kind of
looks like the amygdala which is a boss
from the game bloodborne so just like
they did with the demogorgon it seems
like the depot brothers are pulling from
a lot of different Inspirations to
create this monster but we'll just have
to see exactly what it's called and how
it operates also notice how the sky is
red and streaked with lightning now this
doesn't really look like the upside down
as we remember it so I feel like this
might be a whole new dimension that's
bleeding over into the upside down like
maybe last season what we saw as the
upside down is really just a buffer
Dimension separating our Dimension from
this whole other hellish world that
we'll see in season two let's move on
nothing's gonna go back to the way that
it was
[Music]
not really
I saw something
okay so here we are in the classroom and
we know that this empty seat belongs to
will so Mike looking concerned could
mean that will might go missing again in
this season of course he could just be
missing school for these tests that we
see in this other shot we actually saw
this same security footage in the last
teaser but that footage had a date on it
but now it's been removed so it seems
like maybe will is missing school on the
day before Halloween I'm not really sure
why they wouldn't want us to know that
now anyway give me your thoughts on why
you think that was removed in the
comments down below by the way I think
that scientist who's examining will in
this shot could be the actor Paul Reiser
now Riser has been cast as a character
named Dr Owens he's the guy from the
Department of energy who's in charge of
containing the disaster from season one
The Duffer Brothers wanted to bring
Riser on board as a nod to him playing a
similar character in the aliens movies
which of course were big influences on
stranger things he played Burke who was
an employee of the Weyland Corporation
who heartlessly prioritizes scientific
discovery over the lives of these poor
innocent people so I'm guessing he might
be playing a similar type of figure in
stranger things allowing the buyer's
family and the people of Hawkins to be
guinea pigs while the government is able
to continue their research and actually
in between these shots we get a quick
look at Nancy and Steve the power couple
we kind of hated at first but then later
rooted for yeah it looks like there's
trouble in Paradise now this is
obviously a fight about Nancy being
pregnant with a demogorgon slug baby
wait a minute am I the only one to
believe that theory or I'm thinking
Steve might be frustrated by Nancy's
lingering friendship with Jonathan or
maybe new feelings for the new kid on
the Block Billy now he's supposed to be
a ladies man and interestingly the actor
was told to study Jack Nicholson's
character in The Shining as inspiration
for his character yeah how could you not
fall in love with that before I move on
notice this shot of these pumpkins they
look hollowed out like maybe something's
been feeding on them or this could be
something else so let's activate Theory
time and you know what this is Halloween
theme so let's make it spooky Theory
time
okay so to me these pumpkins also kind
of look like egg shells like something
might have been incubating inside of
them and now it is hatched Out imagine a
pumpkin version of these xenomorph eggs
and Aliens I feel like it would be so
true to these stranger things Spirit to
ground this 80s style sci-fi into
something so familiar and residential
the way that in season one they use
seasonal iconography of Christmas lights
and transformed it into something
Supernatural also we know that episode 3
of season 2 will be called the pumpkin
patch so something important is going to
be happening with these pumpkins
actually remember the slug that will
coughed up and it slithered down the
drain at the end of season one maybe
that slug made it into the sewers and
then later crawled out and laid eggs
inside of all these pumpkins and then
each one hatched out of it honestly I
just want to see a scene with a family
in Hawkins trying to carve a pumpkin and
the moment the knife is about to go in a
baby creature bursts out of it and
scurries out the door okay I'm I might
just be letting my imagination run wild
let's move on
no
[Music]
The Darkness Falls across the land
Midnight Hour is close at hand
creatures crawl in search of blood to
terrorize your's neighborhood
whosoever shall be found sometimes I
feel like
I still see it
I stand and face the house of hell and
rot inside a Corpse's shell
okay so after this look at Noah
schnapp's amazing acting as this
terrified will we hear the iconic
Vincent Price narration from Michael
Jackson's Thriller really Thriller is
the perfect song choice for stranger
things it's super 80s and also super
creepy I love how this trailer evokes
John landis's short film for the song
showing the shot of these Halloween
decoration tombstones with a skeleton
hand reaching out of a grave which feels
like a reference to a similar shot
during the price narration section of
Thriller now speaking of the music
notice that when we move on to this next
shot of a scientist freaking out as his
terminals lighting up if you listen
closely you can hear some of these synth
strings mixed in with the music of
Thriller
season one actually used this same sound
effect when the lights of the buyer's
house went haywire at the time it
suggested a link with the upside down
that's clearly what's happening here and
then after we get this I'm in a shot of
Dustin scene drops of blood we get this
really fun establishing shot of the
wheeler house and there's a campaign
sign in the front yard for Reagan Bush
84. of course season two will take place
on Halloween 1984 which is just a week
before that presidential election and I
don't think we need to look too deep
into the politics of this I just like
how this is another example of the
Nostalgia and the set design like if you
were a family in Indiana in 1984 you
were more than likely a Reagan family it
was a landslide election actually back
in season one Mr Wheeler made his
political views pretty clear oh my God
is she Russia let's move on okay here we
get this master group shot of everyone
in there awesome Ghostbuster costumes I
love how everyone in this trailer is
dressed at Halloween costumes of
whatever the big movie was that year of
course any group of four friends are
going to be dressed up as a Ghostbusters
so notice that Dustin is Stan will is
Spangler Lucas is Venkman and Mike is
Winston then we see Hopper looking at
this contour map of Hawkins notice how
there's this removed section in the
middle I'm guessing that's Hawkins lab
because it's a super secret government
lab that they probably didn't want to
Maps but then notice all the X's around
it I'm guessing these are all for recent
paranormal occurrences or sightings and
Hopper is realizing that they're all
stemming from this lab and then next we
see the new girl in class and the new
girl on the show Max she's played by
Sadie sink actually the first episode
will be called Mad Max and it's probably
about her I mean just look how mad she
is now I could see Max kind of becoming
in romantic interest to one of these
guys but it's pretty clear that Mike's
heart still seems to belong to 11. just
look how wistfully he gazes at this
little hobo Hut that he made for her and
still has actually if you listen here
you can hear eleven's voice saying
okay my favorite shot of this trailer is
this one of Dustin creeping up to this
trash can armed with his Ghostbuster
proton gun now remember Dustin is stance
and I feel like this fearful slow
approach is exactly like that scene with
stance and Slimer in the first
Ghostbuster movie and I've told him
myself
and yeah I just love the way Dustin
keeps this thing whatever it is inside a
trap just like the Ghostbusters do with
all of their paranormal entities really
this is just like the kids applying the
DND logic to the demogorgon it's cool to
see the Ghostbuster logic actually work
for them I just hope someone calls
somebody in the season let's
move on whatever is happening
spreading from this place
[Applause]
[Music]
so as we hear Hopper's voice say
whatever is happening
we see shots of him finding this
ectoplasm on a tree and Nancy and
Jonathan back in Hawkins lab to see what
Hopper is referring to the rift that
leads to the upside down now remember we
never saw this seal up at the end of
season one so it's still here and it
appears to have grown and it makes sense
that more things beyond the demogorgon
could come through and infest the town
of Hawken good thing they have the best
exterminators money can buy we also see
some shots of will drawing like crazy
which as we know from the little boy in
the ring is never a good sign later on
we see the shot of Joyce and Hopper
trying to connect all these on the floor
we also see them pinned up on the wall
now some people are saying that will is
drawing this monster that he keeps
seeing in his Visions but I actually
think that what he's drawing is a match
showing tunnels that form an alternate
path to the upside down like I think
throughout this trailer when we see
everyone navigating through tunnels
they're actually following this map that
will Drew for them okay so then after
this awesome Avenger style team-up shot
with a crew circled up Nancy ready to
Sharp shoot some Demon and Mike well I
guess Mike's gonna give them a real wall
up with that Candlestick we see this
super Rowdy High School Halloween party
and yeah it looks like in season two
stranger things is going to continue
that depiction of high school social
life in that same tone of Freaks and
Geeks and John Hughes movies maybe a
little Dazed and Confused mixed in there
and if you look closely you can see that
all these costumes are year appropriate
there's a kid on the left dressed as
Johnny from The Karate Kid that movie
actually came out the summer before in
1984 and then the girl in the background
is dressed as Madonna from Like a Virgin
which also debuted in 1984 and I think
this guy with the red bandana might be
trying to rock a Bruce Springsteen look
from Born in the USA that dropped the
previous summer as well now I'm not sure
at all who Nancy and Steve are supposed
to be like maybe with that black outfit
and sunglasses Steve is Johnny Cash I
don't know that'd be kind of a dated
reference for 84. then we cut to the
shot of a flamethrower and a person a
hazmat suit torching the upside down
Rift entrance so it seems like someone
is taking things in their own hands to
try to kill whatever's coming through
this portal also I just love the
flamethrower as a weapon it's kind of
the classic 80s sci-fi weapon memorably
it was used in the thing and Aliens now
before I move on I still don't really
know what's happening in this shot of
hopper in a cabin as it's being torn up
and debris flying everywhere but
remember episode 7 is called the secret
cabin I actually think this is the cabin
from that episode let's move on
oh boy
okay we get another great shot of this
trailer as Hopper goes down this tunnel
as it literally Turns Upside Down I
actually really like how the shot frames
him to evoke the iconic silhouette of
Indiana Jones the videos I made about
season one I pointed out how David
Harbor kind of seems to be drawing
inspiration from Harrison Ford and his
portrayal of the character think this
Indie style hat plays a big part of why
we find his character so heroic okay
then we get another big Cameo Sean Aston
you might know him as Samwise gamgee
from Lord of the Rings but long before
that he played Mikey in The Goonies
which was another huge influence on
Stranger Things Mikey was actually
mentioned as a big inspiration for the
character of Mike wheeler while Dustin
is pretty clearly an amalgamation of
mouth and chunk
[Music]
a 1981
like Paul Reiser Aston was cast largely
for his connection to these 80s movies
and here he plays Bob Newby Joyce's new
boyfriend and he's wearing hospital
scrubs here which is kind of weird
because his character has been described
as an owner of a Radio Shack so what do
we think is going on here well check out
the background of the shot those are
definitely some cops or security guards
who are slumped over on the floor I
think Bob is on some mission on behalf
of Joyce and maybe the kids I think he's
going undercover in this hospital and
maybe Hopper would have gone with him on
that mission and while Bob was trying to
do things discreetly Hopper just said
what would Indy do and knock the hell
out of these guys
I don't know let me know what you think
is going on here in the comments okay
then after this badass shot with
Jonathan I think it's Jonathan with a
baseball bat with nails sticking out of
it and this goonie style shot of the
gang we see will running through the
upside down version of his school as
some Darkness chases him so this could
just be a vision that will is
experiencing like in a second he's gonna
blink and wake up and find this hallway
filled with normal students who are all
pissed off at him for pushing past them
and knocking over their science project
but I'm not really sure what this
monster is it kind of reminds me of the
smoke monster from lost but it's
interesting how it looks like the floor
is giving out kind of like the Stephen
King movie The Langoliers
Stephen King of course was a huge
influence on season one but also I think
the floor giving away could be like it
does in the game The Dragon's Lair like
I have a good feeling that we're going
to see elements of that video game make
their way back into the show as real
threats that will and his friends have
to face all right let's move on to this
final section
[Laughter]
ha
okay so just as we saw in that Super
Bowl teaser 11 lives she wakes up in
this upside down version of the
classroom we saw her which the shot
cleverly shows by making her upside down
and notice how there's no trace of the
demogorgon or will for that matter this
is interesting you would think you would
see some corpse or particles of the
demogorgon around that room but not us
so is the demogorgon still alive also it
seems like 11 has found a new Rift back
into this Dimension through the school
wall but that seems a little easy right
like to have 11 vanish for months just
to have her walk down the hallway and
find a way back into our world I'm
wondering if this hallway that she's
pushing into isn't the normal dimension
of Hawkins I think this could be a third
dimension that we haven't seen before
remember in season one their science
teacher used that analogy of the flea
and the acrobat to describe
interdimensional travel so the flea can
walk upside down on the Rope but it can
also walk on the side of the Rope or
really any degree along the
circumference of that rope so my point
is I don't think our Dimension and the
upside down are the only two Dimensions
that exist in the universe and stranger
things like this is The Duffer Brothers
we're talking about why not just use
season one as a starting point to where
we can build out and explore all this so
I think that in Season Two Eleven and
Will are going to see what lies Beyond
let me know down below your thoughts
about this trailer and some predictions
and theories that I brought up the new
monster those pumpkin shells where 11 is
exactly and the significance of the game
The Dragon's Lair let's keep this
conversation going all the way to the
season 2 premiere on October 27th you
can hit me up on Twitter at eavos or
follow new rockstars on Twitter at new
rockstars and if you really like this
channel you can contribute to us on
patreon big thanks to all of our donors
especially Matthew salvos thank you for
watching and
snowing
oh damn it okay um I gotta feel around
for a switch
oh Jesus everything's sticky
foreign